what kind of kid were you growing up i'm
just curious growing up in the city is
so much different than growing up in you
know a small town or anything i was
exposed to so much at such a young age
but i didn't i
played pretend a lot like i i you had a
good imagination i had a really big
imagination yeah i mean i i sang at the
opera from when i was a kid and i loved
writing in my diaries in fact i was just
home and i found all these old diaries
that i had had when i was a kid and
my imagination was amazing i mean i was
i was uh married to prince harry in
these diaries and um that sounds crazy
uh you
i'm just diagnosing you as i speak to
you yeah no but uh as a kid you believed
that you were married to prince harry
sort of like i just had this alternative
life and all these imaginary friends
where i was princess and
yeah yeah that's okay i think a lot of
it's funny because uh i have a daughter
who talks about wanting to be a princess
but the specific specificity of saying
prince harry i'm going to die i'm with
prince harry well i like a
[Applause]
he's the bad boy yeah well we are the
bad guys
that was always my role in high school
i was the bad guy the dark just last
night i actually had a dream that i uh
was married to prince harry and kate
middleton and i were best friends and
wait a minute really uh-huh you're
kidding totally so and was this a a
pretty chase it was vivid vivid was it
did it get a little raunchy i woke up
pumping my stuffed animal
that happened you really
okay uh
that's that's that's cool uh
i i'm just that just that just wiped my
brain clean i don't know where to go now
you got the uh picturing all kinds of
stuff now what kind of stuffed animal is
it is it an elmo is it a
cause you said you like a ginger so
it's a gunned polar bear
it's a polar bear fantastic okay um we
need a commercial break here i can't
i need oxygen uh
um let's let me ask you something very
quickly uh because we're going to do a
commercial break but i want to ask you
about shameless you do all kinds of i
mean this is a show where you guys
you you push the envelope a little bit
on the show it's crazy yeah it's very
racy show this clearly spilled over into
my life because now i'm having all sorts
of vivid dreams about royalty this is
not good yeah you know you're you're
molesting bears and polar bears
right but on the show shameless there's
there's a lot of
you know sex and drugs and drinking do
you ever worry that you're going too far
do you guys on the set ever think i
think this time we've gone too far
there was only one time when i thought
that we were doing a scene where uh it's
a flashback in the woman who plays uh my
character's grandmother it's her it's
the scene about uh how she dies and
basically she overdoses doing blow and
we had this 93 year old actress there um
who
was
you know a day player and she came in
and she had to do this line of blow and
then fake an overdose and it was
actually her birthday she was turning 93
on that day
so you you brought a 93 year old woman
in and said we need you to pretend and
obviously it's not real cocaine no it's
baby laxative actually it's like
powdered baby laxatives so that sounds
more dangerous than
yeah
that sounds more lethal to me i think if
you give a 92 year old woman cocaine
before you give her baby laxatives she
clearly had never done it before because
she was exhaling
so we had to i felt i thought the moment
i thought we're really going to hell is
when we had to teach her how to let's do
it you taught this 93 year old and now
she's helplessly addicted to baby
laxatives yeah
terrific all right we're getting one of
charlie sheen's new goddesses
way to go